foreign
let's get to Christy
in Old Milwaukee
Kelly's favorite beer all right what's
up Christy
yeah hi Dr John how are you doing today
I'm so good how are you
good
what's happening oh
I'm question free I'm gonna I'm gonna
read it so that I'm a little more
coherent I'm a little nervous but don't
be nervous but coherence is so good
yes
how can
how can lying to save my marriage
married to my husband for almost four
years
um this is a second marriage for both of
us and we both have grown children who
live on our own
uh more empty nesters now but my husband
and my children have never really gotten
along and I always kind of feel stuck in
the middle
um we can't do holidays together or
anything else for that matter I try not
to bring up anything to do with my kids
if I have a day off and I plan to spend
it with my daughters I try to avoid the
topic
um he tells me he never wants to
discourage me from spending time with
them but for some reason I always feel
guilty if I even bring up anything that
has to do with them
um why so if you ask what I'm
I feel like
um with my my ex-husband was very
controlling
and very emotionally abusive
and I know my husband now is not like
that at all but I still feel like
it's a I don't know if I'd say it's a
defense mechanism
but but why can't your kids and him be
in the same room I can all do holidays
together
I feel like they've done things in the
past that kind of sabotage certain
things who's like your kids
my kids yes
so like for instance they showed up
really late to our wedding that was one
thing my husband will bring up
um and it was a very small wedding it
was just a handful of us and we couldn't
do anything because they hadn't shown up
um how long ago was that
that was almost four years ago
and how old are these kids
they're in their 20s they're I mean
they're all adults they all live on
their own two of them are married
but what I'm getting at is so your 20
year old kids
they had a little Timber tantrum power
play
on your wedding that was dumb and
immature like 20 year olds are
right your grown-up husband
can't sit back and be like hey the
family that they thought they were gonna
have has been ex has exploded and I'm
new and I'm gonna take some getting used
to and I'm gonna have to be the mature
one here for a season he can't do that
he has to act like a child too
things that way yeah
I end up like trying not to bring up
anything that has to do with my kids
which really shouldn't be an issue but
it seems like we absolutely the only
argument the only arguments we ever have
have to do with my kids to be honest
that's a huge deal though it's like
saying the only thing that's hard for me
is breathing
right that's that's your life those are
your kids
I know is he is your husband
um
does he I hear this often when folks get
remarried and they marry somebody who
wants to pretend their new spouse's
previous life didn't happen didn't exist
so that they can have them all to
themselves and I hear it's often women
who have men with children
and they want to pretend that that ex
that that man was not with somebody else
and had kids with somebody else and had
intense intimate moments with somebody
else and the kids are annoying it's rare
that I see it flipped but but here we
are is it possible that your husband
just wants to pretend that your previous
world didn't exist and he's got you all
to himself
I don't feel like that's the case I feel
like more he's I I think from his
perspective I tend to baby my kids
and so he's just like let them be adults
like they're on their own now let them
fend for themselves kind of thing
whereas I always feel like
I'm still around and I'm still her mom
and so like yes I still want to be there
to support my kids what does support
mean
like that but just so he doesn't want
you talking to them
no he'll he'll say I can I mean and he
says I he doesn't want to interfere with
my relationship with them yeah I know
but he is
but he is so you've heard me say this on
the show a million times behavior is a
language he can say whatever he wants I
don't give a crap what he says I care
what he does and almost as as important
as what he does it's how he makes you
feel whenever you're doing whatever it
is you're doing
and if you're on the phone with your
daughter or you're on the phone with
your son
who happens to be an immature 20
something year old they're gonna have to
get in a long line on that one
and do you suddenly feel like I have to
shut this thing down or I'm gonna have
hell to pay in this house and it might
not be physical hell to pay or it might
not be verbal hell to pay but it's that
disgusting look at oh my gosh I got
married an idiot I married some soft old
lady like and you have to lie and shut
it down
um behavior is a language dude
right
yeah
I feel like like I can talk with my kids
without a problem but I feel like if I I
work options and so I feel almost guilty
on my the days that he has to go to work
where I can just spend a day with the
kids or spend the day with my grandkids
and that's on you that's on you those
are your feelings
mm-hmm now let me push on that a bit
you feel guilty you feel all these
things and you said some of that is
lingering from your past marriage where
maybe if you did spend a day with the
kids you had hell to pay when you got
home
are you unfairly
um taking a picture of your old
ex-husband and cutting it out and
pasting it on the face of your current
husband
has he ever said when he gets home from
work like oh my gosh you're not here
you're with your stupid kids has he ever
said that
even hinted at that
no he hasn't
um why are you doing that to yourself
that's a really good question
because I do feel like I I do have a
tendency to put him in that place of
like
and he'll tell me I'm not your ex I'm
not
this person that used to belittle you
and say things
like that
um so here's the deal people people lie
for on the whole for one of three
reasons number one there's there have a
pathology right they're psychotic they
think that they're smarter than
everybody around them
the second reason people lie is to to
keep himself safe
like I have to lie or somebody's like
are your kids in that house no they're
not there I'm gonna lie to keep myself
not harmed the third one is
um to preserve relationship it's social
status is in the nerd literature
I I'm gonna try to keep this fantasy
going that everything's okay
which one of the reasons of those three
reasons are the reasons that you don't
tell your husband the truth that you run
around behind his back
mm-hmm
do you feel unsafe are you trying to
pretend that everything's okay
um I feel like it's it probably is to be
safe but it's more
to avoid an argument
no but you're not telling me about any
argument you have
why would you argue
we end up arguing over
I guess every once in a while it will be
spending time with the kids or how come
you're with I I know I'm talking in
circles
um
here's what it sounds like if I'm gonna
be super honest with you
yes
it sounds like he's
um
an abusive jerk that you're trying to
protect but also quietly covertly asked
questions on how you can live in that
world
or
you have created a fantasy narrative
that he is going to be bad too and so
you curb your actions and behaviors when
it comes to the most important people in
your life which are your kids
and then you blame him
for your behavioral choices
that he has nothing to do with
and then in the blame you all get in a
fight and you end up arguing about
things it's one of those two things
which one is it
I feel like it's probably the second one
you don't go visit your kids when you
want to or they say hey mom come over
and see us and you're like well I gotta
be home because husband gets home soon
and then he gets home 20 minutes late
and you are enraged
not because he's 20 minutes late or not
because he came home not because you're
not happy to see him but because he kept
you from seeing your kids and really he
didn't and then you act short or you act
a little bit mean and then he responds
to that and now we're in a fight and
you're saying the fight's about the kids
and it's really not is that fair
it can be yeah yeah I would say that's
fair
I am concerned that he isn't sitting
down saying hey we have to heal this
we all have to be able to be in a room
together
or is it you keeping everybody from
being in the same room together
no I
brought that up I'm like I think
this is getting ridiculous yes correct
um but at the same time he's like
they're not going to want to hear what I
have to say and it's just gonna blow up
and that's how he feels and what is he
what kind of is he gonna try to parent
them
no no I think he would just tell them to
basically just grow up and stop acting
like children ironically because that's
kind of how he's acting it's a hundred
percent he's like I'm taking my ball and
going home I want an immature guy like
what are they what are they doing that's
I'm fascinated by this what are they
doing that is so immature
they got jobs they're financially on
their own and they call their mom once a
week or twice a week to check in like
what is so immature about what they how
they live
well I'd say that they call me pretty
much every day for something okay or
other they'll ask me for advice for
different things or they'll
we
especially my girls were real close so
we do talk quite often so one thing
that's super common
about
um if you lived under the rule of of an
abusive spouse
for a period of time
and the result is a divorce but that
abuse and that hunkering down happens
years before the papers are finalized
kids in a protective spouse will circle
the wagons and have a very deep
connected sometimes a mesh sometimes un
um healthy but often very tight knit
relationship because they had to to
survive
and I think that was us
we had a very very close relationship
and so you have to be careful as they're
adults to not use them now to prop you
up
and
you have to teach them how to fly
and say things like here's a good
example I called
um this is several years ago now I had a
student who had passed away and I had to
make an announcement to a bunch of his
friends
and I called my mentor the guy that
first taught me how to make these kind
of phone calls and I said hey here's
what I'm about to do and he and he said
John listen
what you just said is right and you
don't need to call me anymore you you
know what you're doing and I trust you
they trust you and they're lucky to have
you
and so did you see what I'm saying like
he heard me he affirmed what I was doing
and then he also ended with and you
don't need to call me every time
and so it feels good when your kids call
you every day and ask you for questions
and ask you for hey should I do this
should do this that feels so good and so
empowering and at some point you're
using them to make you feel important
that's that's a heavy burden for your
kids to carry
so if they call you to ask you about car
insurance you can say yeah I would use
this the insurance we use and I like it
and by the way you don't need to call me
every time for car insurance I trust you
you're a good kid
see what I'm saying there's those little
nuggets to say there you go
to more Empower them and not exactly
have them depend on me fair but all of
that is gonna take some healing time
and it sounds like honestly everybody
needs to grow up
you him kids everybody needs to grow up
and he doesn't have any position right
now to be lecturing your chill your
grown children
what he does have is hey uh I'm watching
my wife wither and die here
because I'm forcing her to not be whole
or you Christy are choosing to not be
whole
because you're not going all in on this
marriage right
mm-hmm
I feel like I have to live in two
different lives like I my lives don't
mesh
I don't know if that makes sense it does
but I want you when you hear this call
come out I want you to hear how many
times you said the words I feel I feel I
feel
and I want you to write down what you
and then I want you to demand evidence
from those feelings because I have a
sense that those feelings are very very
real but they are not telling you the
truth
that could be
and maybe you take husband out
um for a lunch on a Saturday or for
breakfast on a Saturday and you have
spent two weeks writing down your
quote-unquote feelings
and you can ask him hey I'm going to run
these feelings by you these are mine
these are all mine
these are stories I'm telling myself as
brene Brown says and that's how me and
my wife do it the stories I'm telling
myself are
I have to live two lives because you
can't be around my kids and if you are
around my kids you feel like you gotta
lecture them the story I'm telling
myself is our marriage isn't going to
ultimately work out because I'm not
going to choose my kids um you over my
kids the story I'm telling myself is I'm
a terrible mom because you say I talk to
my children too much and they're adults
and I want you to go down all those
stories and let him respond to those
things
and at some point you're gonna have to
decide
I'm going to let my needs be heard and
my needs are I need everybody that I
love and care about in the same room my
grown kids and my husband
and I gotta quit living two lives and
your grown kids can opt out they can say
we don't like this too we want to be
gone and they can they get to do that
they get to do that and I guess at the
end of the day your husband gets to
choose that too he's a grown-up and you
get to decide whether you want to be
married to a man who won't be in the
same room with your kids that's on you
but at the end of the day you all have
to make some hard choices but those hard
choices start with you being honest
about
feelings and reality you got to choose
reality and you got to be willing to
have your needs be met just say them out
loud and say here's what I need I need
everybody under the same roof I need
everybody acting like adults and I'm
willing to go first
I think this is a solvable problem
Christy I really do
I think you might be getting in your own
way
and maybe for the first time in your
life you can allow yourself to finally
be loved
when you're just gonna have to practice
what that feels like it's going to take
a season